By the end of Bloodshot, Ray Garrison is finally
starting to piece together his past — his
real past.
Who was Ray before he became Bloodshot?
How did he die in the first place?
And what's this all building to, anyway?
We've got the answers — well, most of them,
anyway.
In Bloodshot, most of what we learn about
Ray Garrison simply isn't true.
The daring hostage rescue that opens the film
is a fabricated "hero module" designed to
give him confidence.
His relationship with Gina ended five years
ago.
She wasn't killed.
She wasn't even his wife.
"They've been manipulating you."
So, by the end of the movie, what do we know
about him?
Well, going off of a few stray lines of dialogue,
we can safely say that Ray really was part
of the military.
Gina — the real one — notes that Ray kept
leaving on classified missions.
He might've come home every time, but Gina
couldn't deal with him leaving in the first
place.
That's why their relationship ended.
We also know that Ray has a keen sense of
justice, a righteous temper, and doesn't let
go of a grudge.
Bloodshot's whole thesis, which is summed
up at the end of the movie, is that memories
don't make the man.
Actions do.
As such, there's no reason to look backwards.
The specifics of Ray's past might remain a
mystery, but it doesn't matter.
He's moving forward regardless.
For such a brutal story, Bloodshot has a surprisingly
uplifting ending.
The bad guys are dead.
Gina is safe and has moved on.
Bloodshot's biggest limitation — the way
his nanites ran out of power, forcing him
to stop and recharge — has been removed.
Now, it's just Ray, KT, Wilfred Wigans, their
shared trailer, and a beautiful oceanside
paradise.
It's perfect — maybe a little too perfect.
RST's entire scheme hinged on its ability
to manipulate Ray's reality.
Who's to say they're not doing it again?
That's what Wilfred wonders right before the
film smash cuts to the credits.
It's what KT implies when she says that their
tropical surroundings are a dream.
Wilfred has a new, very different set of clothes.
The final scene's warm lights and bright color
palette recall Ray and Gina's trip to Italy,
which was also a fantasy invented by RST.
Now, this isn't Inception.
Bloodshot isn't a particularly subtle movie,
and we're probably supposed to take everything
we see at face value.
Still, if Sony wanted to open a Bloodshot
sequel by revealing that this happy ending
wasn't so happy at all, it wouldn't be a surprise.
The groundwork has already been laid.
"What you think is real, sometimes ain't.”
For all intents and purposes, Bloodshot is
married.
It's the fictional death of his fake wife,
Gina, that spurs Bloodshot into action.
Without that connection, false as it might
be, RST's whole plan for manipulating Ray
falls apart.
And yet, if you thought you picked up on some
sexual tension between Ray and KT in the film's
final scene, you're not alone.
KT totally has the hots for Ray, and it seems
like Ray is starting to feel the same way.
Because of the movie's premise — KT could
fall in love with Ray over time, but not the
other way around — their romance had to
take an unusual form.
As director Dave Wilson told us,
"Because of Bloodshot's total memory loss,
this could never be a conventional love relationship.
I wanted a love story that the audience didn't
see coming."
Of course, the movie drops plenty of hints
that Bloodshot and KT are going to end up
as an item.
When a devastated Ray learns that nobody came
to collect his body, KT reassures him that
there's someone out there who loves him.
At the time, you're supposed to think KT is
referring to Gina, who's still alive, but
no — she's talking about herself.
While the movie's ending doesn't reveal Bloodshot's
identity, his comics do.
Well, kind of.
Fittingly, Bloodshot's backstory has been
rebooted and retconned many times since the
character's 1992 debut, and it's hard to pin
down an exact origin story.
Ironic, right?
At least poor Ray comes by it honestly.
In the first volume of Bloodshot, which was
originally written by Kevin VanHook and drawn
by Don Perlin, the titular hero was revealed
to be a violent mobster named Angelo Mortalli.
Ruthless and driven, Mortalli was a rising
star in Don Gino Canelli's crime family until
Canelli learned that Mortalli was cheating
on his fiancee — who just happened to be
Canelli's daughter.
Canelli framed Mortalli for a violent crime,
forcing Mortalli into witness protection,
where he was killed by a corrupt FBI agent.
Rising Spirit got its hands on him shortly
thereafter.
The name Ray Garrison didn't enter Bloodshot
canon until volume two launched in 1997, as
one of Bloodshot's other alternate identities.
Over the years, he's had plenty of others.
These days, Bloodshot assumes that "Ray" is
his real personality and that Angelo was a
cover he adopted while on a classified mission,
although he doesn't know for sure.
At this rate, he never will.
Here's the thing, though: The cinematic Bloodshot
could still go the Angelo Mortalli route,
assuming that the movie gets a sequel.
According to former Valiant Entertainment
CEO Dinesh Shamdasani, early drafts of the
Bloodshot script leaned heavily into the mafia
angle, and the film's lack of definite answers
leaves room for Mortalli to appear in the
sequel.
In fact, we already have one hint that Bloodshot's
ending is a little deceptive, and that Ray
— or whoever he actually is — isn't exactly
the stand-up guy the finale makes him out
to be.
During one of Bloodshot's action scenes, Dr.
Harting taunts Ray by noting that the soldier
signed up for military service because he
enjoys violence.
Ray protests, but the evidence is all there
on screen.
Let's face it: Hijacking an airplane and killing
half a dozen people isn't exactly a normal
response to trauma.
"You know nothing about men like me!"
It's an interesting concept, and one that
could make for an interesting angle in a sequel.
By the end of the movie, Bloodshot says he's
done looking backwards, but learning that
he was more of a villain than a hero pre-transformation
could make him change his mind.
Of all the different iterations of Bloodshot,
the film draws the most heavily on the 2012
reboot, which really played up the entire
false memories and mind control angles.
In that story, Bloodshot learns that he's
being manipulated fairly early on, and takes
the war to Rising Spirit fairly quickly.
That's where the movie ends, but if Bloodshot's
sequels continue down that path, then we know
exactly where this story is going.
In the comics, Bloodshot learns he's not Project
Rising Spirit's only victim.
Over the years, the project has also been
kidnapping children with superpowers, who
are known as harbingers.
By making Bloodshot think that the kids are
in danger, Rising Spirit has been relying
on the supersoldier to round up the powerful
little tykes.
Bloodshot drops the kids off at the project's
labs, where they're caged and experimented
on, then has his memory wiped before he sets
off for the next batch.
Naturally, Bloodshot frees the kids when he
learns what's going on, but dropping two dozen
super-powered children into the real world
without any warning has big repercussions.
In the comics it led to a massive crossover
event called "Harbinger Wars."
In theaters, it could lead to a similar, Avengers-style
event — if one major obstacle doesn't get
in the way.
Originally, Harbinger Wars was Valiant and
Sony's endgame.
In 2015, The Hollywood Reporter confirmed
that Bloodshot — then scheduled for a 2017
release, with John Wick's Chad Stahelski and
David Leitch set to direct — was going to
be the first entry in Valiant's big-screen
superhero universe.
Harbinger would be the second.
Each movie would get a sequel, and then the
two franchises would crossover for the Harbinger
Wars event.
However, in 2019, the Harbinger movie moved
from Sony to Paramount.
With the characters now at two separate companies,
a crossover seems increasingly unlikely.
It could still happen, of course — Sony
itself has already teamed up with Marvel Studios
to bring Spider-Man into the MCU, although
that relationship has been relatively complicated
— but the chances aren't great.
When we asked Bloodshot director Dave Wilson
about a potential sequel, he was quick to
list all the places a larger Bloodshot universe
could go.
"There are groups and characters that I love,
from Bloodsquirt to Bloodhound to H.A.R.D.
Corps.
There is enough material out there in the
Valiant universe to make any number of films
you want."
Tellingly, though, while those characters
do interact with the larger Valiant universe,
they're primarily Bloodshot spinoffs.
At this point in time, a larger Valiant series
with Bloodshot at the center seems like a
fairly dicey proposition.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies and TV shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.